Today I am sooo EXCITEEEEEEEEEEDDD!!!
Because! We're gonna watch, you and I,
my favorite stream of all time.
It is so goddamn painful to watch.
But that's how you know that shit is gooood!
The thing about streams is that,
once the content is up there
It's there forever, and that's the beauty of it.
I-- I'm always extremely paranoid whenever I stream that I'm gonna say something or do something
That people will judge me... Anyway, let's laugh at some other people being awkward!
(Laughs)
All right, so this stream is for Summer Games Done Quick 2014. It's a speedrun of Tomba 2
Look at that, incredible!
Don't get me wrong, I-- I think speedruns can be really interesting.
*THUD* Oh my god, my camera just fell..
Don't get me wrong, I'm not here to trash speedruns
I think it can be really interesting and really impressive what people do with their spare time cuz jesus fucking Christ. I'm kidding
I'm kidding. Now let's go back to the video
I was 100% sure it said autistic there because I think it takes a special kind of mind to do this.
Chibi: This... looks fun
So we got
Cavemen, the guy with a mustache, and what I
*sexxyyy burp*
And the guy next to him, Chibi, who invited himself on the couch for the speedrun. Now imagine
Imagine playing the same game over and over and over and over and over and over and it's your time
It's the only skill you have. It's the only talent you really acquire
Which is one talent more than I'll ever have, so don't get me wrong. But still, imagine doing all that
It's your time to shine, it's your time to show it all off and then this motherfucker
Chibi
Invites himself to the couch next to you, to steal your spotlight
Let's watch.
Caveman DCJ: Hello everyone, I am Caveman DCJ
and this is Tomba 2
Oh, that's a good start.
Chibi: Well I mean it's more plot than Bubsy has!
So Chibi keeps trying to fill
Fill in the blanks you know which I can respect Chibi for doing. First of all, Chibi is the only guy
*hehehueuehe*
Man, I love how Chibi is the only guy manspreading. He clearly went all alpha in on this couch, but Caveman
He's not having it
Dude, I love bagels
It's so yummy. I believe you
We barely getting started and Caveman seem a little bit fed up by Chibi
We all met that one guy that thinks he knows everything and wants to comment about shit
he doesn't know what he's talking about well that's Chibi for you
You know a little social, uh... a little social school from your boy, Pewdiepie
Ultimate Socia-- Socialist
I mean, uh
I mean ultimate social person: If you're doing most of the talking and
the person you're speaking to gives most of the responses like "Okay." "Uh-huh."
"Alright." Then that probably means they are not interested in anything of what you're saying
And you should probably ask them a question instead. I know -- I know! I'm very well versed in the art of social interaction
Fem announcer: All right well we have $20 from Iniffy, "Here's $20! You can have it. Maybe it'll 'come in useful.'"
Oh my god...
And we have $5 from...
Caveman DCJ: ...but we're not going to, because I like the boomerang.
*Exactly two people go "hmph" as a polite laugh.*
God Chibi, you're so awkward, and my man Chibi he has some excellent stand-up comedy
on-the-fly skills. Just look at-- look at this.
(Laughs) That's hilarious!
My man Chibi! Yeahhhhh! Crabs is a good thing.
Look how happy he is. Why is he smiling so much?
Chibi: I've never seen crabs used that way
*dead silence*
Caveman: And you won't ever again.
And hopefully the end of you Chibi *roasted*
I'm kidding. I'm KIDDING
Chibi: *enthusiastic* Yes! Fast Pants!
Caveman: They make you go fast.
Chibi: I want one. Naow.
*Chibi snorts at his own joke*
Excuse me Chibi pants is actually plural
Not a lot of people know about this that aren't fucking morons!
It even said pants!
Caveman: Oh yeah, I would hate to actually, like, have to put the pants on
Chibi: Ehehehehe hehe! *sharp inhale*
Chibi: I mean...
Caveman: Alright R.I.P Ap- R.I.P. Safety Apple. I gotta go.
Chibi: I mean,
*wtf*
Pewds: ooooOOOHHHHHHHH!!!!
Chibi just GO.
No one wants you here Chibayyyyy!
Announcer: We have $20 from Eoin...
He's so happy!
Any form of attention
He just... lits up
Chibi, god bless you.
A lonely -- a lonely child, you know? The only child in the family. That's Chibi right there.
You know it's true. You know it's true.
ANCR: ...TomBee squirrel suit hype! Donating another five dollars if the announcer can pronounce my name right!
*nervous noises* uhhh hopefully I was close!
Chibi, trying to do a deep, gravely voice and failing: Challenge Accepted!
I like how he hesitated a little bit to do that meme
Look at him. He's like, "Should I do a cheeky?
Should I do a cheeky Chibi?" Look at him. Look at him! He goes for it!
Chibi: "Challenge Accepted!"
CHUHLUNGE UK SUP TUD.
So good.
SO GOOD!
Caveman: He doesn't actually talk though. So he would never say that. In any situation.
*Chibi laughs, not reading the room at all*
Pewds: Ohhh my god.
Chibi: You could pretend he does!
This is painful.
Chibi, same voice:
"I have Fast Pants."
Caveman: You get Turbo Pants later.
There's a moment where you just need to be quiet
Like they had a little nice conversation there like a little bit of back and forth
Interaction but then he just has to keep going.
Chibi: Now you're just making me excited.
Caveman: Yeah I don't think you're ready for that.
Chibi: I don't think I am.
Just stop there. Just stop there Chibi and say nothing moooOOORE!
Think I need some time to
"Prepare My Body."
You su -- fan -- f-fucking asshole. God damn it.
Caveman: Alright.
Pewds: (laughs) "Alright."
Chibi: Ohh! Someone else has a birthday today
Caveman: What are the odds?
Chibi: Pfft! Right!?
Oh it's Chibi's birthday. I never realized that.
Maybe that's why Caveman is trying to be nice at some points, you know?
It's Chibi' s birthday. Oh my god that makes this even better
Yes!
Oh my GOD.
You know it's a good joke when you don't laugh and instead you just say, with a dead tone, "Good joke"
That's how you know something is *truly* hilarious. So at this point
How long have they been playing? 18 minutes, It's not even that long
They're supposed to go for an hour and 30 and Caveman, is not having it anymore. He...
He... huehuehuehue
The Cringe has gone too far. He needs to stop he needs to do something
Chibi is not picking up on any of the social cues that uhh that caveman
has been giving him to shut the fuck up
But yes you are correct
Ooooohhh... Chibiii!
Chibiii!!!!
AHAHAHAHAHAHA (gasp) AHAHAHA
Noo... (laugh)
Ohh my god, ooh
Bless. It's my favorite moment ever
It's so mean, but it's so justified at the same time. Here's the thing though, I'm not on either side, okay
I'm a little bit towards Caveman's side because if he invited himself to the couch,
that's fucking annoying
But at the same time I feel bad for Chibi, and I also think they're both
You know sort of in the wrong, I guess in a way, okay, so literally
Thirty minutes later a little less than thirty minutes later, I guess he's been quiet for 30 minutes. It's just been sitting there moping
It's his birthday. He's not happy
This is terrible. He's sunken into the couch...
Announcer: ... cents from TwoStrains,
"I want to hear more of the guy in the green sweatshirt on the couch, please let him talk more."
Yeah-heh-heh!
I like how Caveman like gives him permission to speak
Chibi: Hi.
Oh my God. It's so awkward. I can't.
Chibi: Nice mustache.
Caveman: Thank you.
Chibi: So since you have all the pig bags does that mean you just fight all the bosses now, at once?
Caveman: Yeah, boss rush mode.
Why does this random girl just show up with a paper? Jesus.
Announcer: $5 from DieSOayd,
"Enjoying this run but I'll donate another $10 if green hoodie guy does 10 jumping jacks."
Green hoodie guy!!
Do those-- jump! Oh he's so happy
I told you he's so happy whenever he gets attention
Caveman: So this is just pretty much the point of no return. Like, the first thing you see--
Those are not jumping jacks!
Ahahahaha!
Oh, this is turning me on
Oh my Lord...
Caveman: Great job, guy I don't know.
"Great job, guy I don't know."
You spend an hour together next to each other on a couch, and you've really bonded. You truly bonded
Chibi: Thanks guys you just gave me my exercise of the week
"That Tomba 2 background music complimented the awkwardness so well."
Dudududu... Oh god I'm Chibi. "Thank you for the evil list of pigs in video games."
Caveman: ... such as?
Chibi: Well, Diddy Kong Racing,
Zelda
Mother
Caveman: Thank you for the list of evil pigs in videogames.
Chibi: You' re welcome.
I mean, you did ask. He did ask!
He did ask! Okay? I'm just...
I'm trying to process all of this. Which side are you on? Team Chibi, or team Caveman?
This happened years ago, no one gives a shit anymore
Here's Caveman's response:
Caveman: Did I get mad pussy after my Tomba 2 run?
The short answer is no. The long answer is thank fucking God no.
From what I understand his name was Chibi.
He still plays Tomba?
How can you still play Tomba?
Caveman: From what I understand his name was Chibi
Which is an excellent name for a man.
That is an excellent name for a man
Caveman: I told him to be quiet because he was a fucker, and I didn't ask for him to be on the couch
And he just invited himself on and
sat shoulder length to me so I couldn't move my elbows and just would not shut--
Yeah, 'cause God... God forbid your elbows touch. That would just be making it even more awkward.
Caveman: -- the fuck up. Did anyone see him actually doing those jumping jacks?
Yes!
Caveman: Like Jesus Christ at least like... at least do good proper jumping jacks.
That was Chibi's main mistake.
He did not do
Proper jumping jacks.
Oh, it makes me angry every time...
I'm shaking every time no one does a proper jumping jack. Ugh!
Now if you don't have enough sympathy for Chibi yet, here's a...
Here's a ten minute video of his mom interrupting his speedrun of Paper Mario
Mom: Just take a walk.
I don't care! Okay?
We talked about this shit, about you being at it all night long!
Chibi: But I'm not being on it all night long.
Mom: I don't care if it's a weekend or not, it doesn't matter! Every day runs together for you!
Chibi: No, actually, it doesn't.
What he really needs to tell his mom here is "Excuse me.
I am playing video games slightly faster than your average person. Mom, you need to back out! Back off!
I am living my life right now!"
Let's finish this just so you guys don't think I'm shitting on all over these people. Actually I am, 100%
This clip is my favorite speed run
This is to me
interesting speed runs, because you get hyped as fuck
and just wash your shame
So apparently he got 1:12
On this map
Then the commentary so fucking legendary
Because apparently that's like technically the lowest you can get on this map
And I hadn't been done before or whatever.
Okay where's the--? I was just about to point that out.
I see that clutchness
YEAH!!!!!
So good
Fucking puts me in hype mode every time I watch it.
But yeah, there you go. That's-- that's some awkward
and some awesome speedrunning for you guys.
Let me know in the comments whose side are you on? Team Chibi or team Caveman?
I think I'm leaning towards Caveman.
But I think they're both equally autistic.
Also check out Crowbcat for finding this video and putting it together
That's all for me for now. Thank you guys so much for watching and as always, sister fister!